good for your
yes
because
is
one of my favorite stories
before we get started
good afternoon
i am assistant sheriff john mcgrath
and we're here to brief you
on additional details as we know them
today about the officer-involved
shooting that occurred on thursday
january 6th 2022
this is officer involved shooting number
one for 2022 fatal number one
the same time last year we had zero
oises
this event was initiated as a burglary
at 10 26 a.m on january 6th
the address given was the 6700 block
of francis celia avenue las vegas
they all
this officer-involved shooting occurred
near the intersection of south broadbent
boulevard and cherry street
which is in southeast area command
you can see the scene to my left
the involved officer is jason guerra he
is 40 years old
and has been with the lvmpd since 2005.
in this incident officer cara was armed
with a glock 17
nine millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired four
rounds during this incident
officer guerra is assigned to the
community policing division
southeast area command
suspect in this event is identified as
ricardo antonio otero
he was a 30 year old hispanic male
adult 5 6 170 pounds he is pictured to
my left
in this incident
otero was armed with a large fixed blade
hunting style knife
ontario's charges if he had survived
are a temp burglary while in possession
of a deadly weapon
violation of an extended protective
order
resisting police officer with a weapon
and attempted murder on a police officer
the details of this option-involved
shooting are as follows
on thursday january 6 2022 the lvmpd
dispatch center received a call from a
citizen
reporting an in-progress burglary in the
6700 block of francis celia avenue
the caller stated that his son
ricardo antonio otero
was armed with a knife
and was attempting to break into the
house
dispatch was advised that otero was last
seen walking out of the area
and its description was provided to
officers
due to the fact that otero was
reportedly armed with a knife
the call was classified as a star
protocol de-escalation
criteria for star protocol de-escalation
is as follows
there is credible information that the
subject is armed with a firearm
or other dangerous weapon
and is using it in a manner that can
cause death or serious bodily injury
the subject is acting in a threatening
manner with the weapon
this does not include open carry
subjects
or pocket knives
this designation means that three
officers and a supervisor
will be assigned to the call in an
attempt to de-escalate a volatile
situation
as officers were enroute to this call
they requested medical personnel to
stage nearby
arriving patrol officers spotted otero
on the sidewalk near the intersection
of broadbent boulevard and cherry street
several patrol officers including
officer jason guerra conducted a
pedestrian stop on otero
an officer told otero to step in front
of his patrol vehicle
but otero refused to listen to the
officer
otero dropped the backpack he was
carrying and continue to ignore all
verbal commands from the officer
otero then produced a large hunting
style knife
and started running towards officer
guerra
officer guerra began to walk backwards
attempting to create distance from otero
while telling him to drop the knife
otero refused to drop the knife and
continue to close the distance between
them
otero then charged it off seguera while
holding the large knife in his hand
officer guerra discharged his duty
weapon four times
striking otero causing him to fall to
the ground
otero was transported sunrise hospital
by medical personnel where he succumbed
to his injuries
i will now play you the 911 audio and
then the body worn camera from this
option raw shooting
over here in my house what's your
address
here
hello
actually
with the knife this is your son
yeah it's my father
2034 john six we're gonna go out on a
possible at uh broadband and cherry
hma gray hat gray sweatshirt tan pants
and a black backpack
[Music]
roberto we need you to listen that's it
all right listen to what they're saying
drop the knife
drop the knife
this concludes this briefing for the os
so
i'm not going to go into his criminal
history
um
but as his father told us that he has
some mental health issues and we had
dealt with him when he was in crisis
before
was the tpo filed by the family in that
house
yes
can you explain to us even though he's
got a knife how quickly he can close
that gap between the officer and himself
um maybe we can
he's already ahead of me
so where where the officer parked he was
41 feet away from where the subject
dropped the backpack
and then he's at a position behind his
car door which is why we train our
officers
and then he backed off 75 feet
um
and if you saw his body worn camera he
uh tripped a little bit over the curb
went all the way up to the wall
when he was fa his back was against the
wall
that's when he fired his weapon
he couldn't return any further and the
subject was 12 feet away from him
approximately when he discharges rounds
if we kept playing the body worn camera
you would have seen the suspect charge
at the officer
even even more but we didn't show that
part where he was shot
can you talk about the dso issue
techniques that they're trying to
implement right there
so we started off with the star protocol
which means we have more officers there
generally when people see more officers
they don't
go towards them they usually either give
up or run
and in this case
the two officers were in the one car
which is not picture but it's over here
and he immediately went towards the
single officer in this car
so de-escalation means getting officers
there um in start part of this star
protocol is getting medical there we get
assistance as soon as possible if some
kind of use of force happens
and then backing off as far as you can
in this case because the officer was by
himself and he didn't have the
opportunity to use another tactic other
than deadly force um usually we'd try to
put an action team together and use less
lethal options that just in this case
didn't there wasn't enough time from the
time he dropped the backpack until the
shots were fired was 31 seconds
and we didn't get a sergeant there
that's required on this call but the
sergeant never made it to the cause too
far away and it happened too quickly
about how long from the time of the
request for police to be out there to
the time they arrived about how long of
the time period was that 12 minutes
he was threatening his family
yes he threatened him in the past and
was trying to break into the house with
the knife
and
it sounded like to me that the dad told
them i called the police
and he went through the backyard jumped
the wall onto broadbent and that's where
we found him
thanks everybody i really appreciate you
guys coming out here today
thank you for asking really appreciate
it
two swat officers were injured this
morning
serving a search warrant one was treated
and released
the other one was shot three times
he's still in surgery and i don't have
an update but he is expected to survive
i did see him earlier today this morning
he is in good spirits
thank you
um
you